Let's look at how to track
what users do in your app.
First, you need to identify
what's important to know
about what your users are doing.
Do you care if they set preferences?
Maybe you want to know if they
reach a certain level in your game.
Perhaps you want to know if they ordered
takeout, or if they clicked an ad.
So here's a code to send
an event hit to Analytics.
You create the tracker.
Should know how to do that by now.
Then you use an event builder
to build an event hit.
You set the category,
the action, and the label.
And these three things, the category,
the action, and the label,
are going to show up in
the Analytics Dashboard.
And you put this code wherever
you want to record the event.
So I'd like to know which of
the dinner options are unpopular,
which ones people don't
want to see again.
So I'm going to add the code to track
the event in the method that's called
when the user presses this button.
In this case,
it's the removeMeal method.
So this is the removeMeal method
in the ShowDinnerActivity.
This is the method that gets
clicked when users press the button
to say they don't like a meal.
So this method creates an intent to
start the RemoveMealActivity and
here's where I've added the code
to send a hit to Analytics.
I get the tracker, I build the event.
I've set the category to Dinner actions,
set the action to,
Dislike dinner choice, and here,
I am passing in the selected dinner, so
that I can keep track of actually which
dinner it is that users don't like.
So to see the report for
the events in the Analytics Dashboard,
you go to Behavior,
Events, and Overview.
While you're waiting for
the data to show up in the Analytics
Dashboard, you can check the log in
Android Studio to make sure that
the hits did in fact get sent.
And in the Analytics Dashboard,
in the Events Overview, make sure that
the date range includes today's date.
So I actually had to wait about a half
an hour for these events to show up.
But here they are.
You see the event categories
have only got one category.
You see the actions and
then again I've only got one action.
And you see the labels.
You can drill down into the events,
drill down into the actions.
So here, I can see that the tofu and
coriander salad was the most
disliked with three dislikes and
you can see other data about the event.